[Musik]
immer das tempo da bin ich
es ist schon spät am abend als pädagogin
seinen mietwagen vor dem flachen gebäude
der nasa parkt unzählige male war er
schon hier der radioreporter aus alabama
die glastür dahinter der hässliche raum
der dennoch in all den jahren so etwas
wie ein zweites wohnzimmer geworden ist
auf dem weg zum space shuttle muss er
hier durch durch die anmeldung denn egal
wer man ist und wie oft man hier schon
war
auch wenn er kein unbekannter ist seit
den 80er jahren hat er von jedem shuttle
start live berichtet es hat ein buch
geschrieben the final countdown das ende
des berühmtesten raumschiffs überhaupt
und auch für ihn heißt es abschied
nehmen von einer ära das wird mein 102
shuttle-start und da zähle ich die
vielen staat abbrüche gar nicht mit also
die mannschaft ist startklar das shuttle
aufgetankt und kurz vor dem start gibt
es irgendein problem und das heißt sorry
wir probieren es an einem anderen tag
wo man auch hinsieht das shuttle die
astronauten sie sind überall die stadt
cape canaveral
sie lebt von nichts anderem als der
raumfahrt die kühne vision vom griff
nach den sternen
hier im süden floridas ist die realität
geworden und das ist kein wunder sagen
die leute wir haben uns einfach dazu
entschlossen es ist ein sympathisches
ein unaufgeregtes bewusst sein dass
diese menschen auszeichnet und wer nicht
gerade ein raumschiff baut der gc offen
in cocoa beach gleich um die ecke
[Musik]
es ist kurz nach sieben uhr morgens für
50 journalisten aus ganz europa hieß es
heute früh aufstehen im konvoi nähern
wir uns dem herzen des kennedy space
center wir hier rein will muss sich
gleich mehrfach akkreditieren
der sicherheitsaufwand ist enorm ebenso
groß aber ist das interesse am letzten
nacht start des space shuttle in 48
stunden soll es endlich losgehen
red dragons hat sich schon länger auf
diese reportage vorbereitet irgendetwas
ist anders an dieser reise
die stimmung ist nicht ausgelassen nicht
euphorisch wie so oft in der
vergangenheit präsident obamas
ankündigung das spaceshuttle aufs
altenteil zu schicken kommt hier bei den
menschen gar nicht gut an und die
journalisten bekommen ist zu spüren
viele der leute hier arbeiten seit
jahrzehnten bei der nasa für sie ist das
eine herzensangelegenheit sie setzten
himmel und erde in bewegung um das
shuttle zu starten
man kann sagen sie haben ihr leben dem
shuttle gewidmet und jetzt sieht es so
aus als ob 7000 von ihnen hier am
kennedy space center ihre arbeit
verlieren werden in alabama wo das
marshall space center steht werden 2000
stellen gestrichen
das alles wird für die nasa ein
schmerzhafter prozess werden wer weiß
vielleicht wird das alles am ende ja zu
einem anderen raumfahrtprogramm führen
zu etwas neuem aber erst einmal tut es
den menschen hier nur wie es ist das
ende einer ära
so viel steht fest was jetzt kommt weiß
niemand so genau
geht es noch mal zum mond oder die
präsident bush einst forderte gar zum
mars
[Musik]
[Applaus]
wo steht amerikas raumfahrtprogramm
heute drei jahrzehnte nach dem ersten
flug des space shuttle
ob sie es glauben oder nicht wir stehen
jetzt wieder dort wo wir waren als das
apollo programm beendet wurde
präsident nixon musste sich entscheiden
was die nasa wohl als nächstes tut es
gab leute die sagten wir waren auf dem
mond packen wir jetzt nicht etwas
größeres an
weil es aber eigentlich kein geld für
etwas größeres gab haben sie der nasa
das spaceshuttle bewilligt das
allerdings fesselte die nasa für 30
jahre an eine niedrige erdumlaufbahn
eine menge leute haben während dieser
zeit nur darauf gewartet aus diesem
fenster auszubrechen und weiter in den
weltraum vorzudringen
etwa zum mars zum mond irgend etwas
spannendes eben das ist genau die
situation die wir heute haben jeder
wartet darauf dass präsident obama sagt
lasst uns was neues was anderes an
flughafen houston in texas southwest
flug 1600 aus los angeles ist pünktlich
im cockpit kevin kriegel
zweimal saß der als kommandant im
spaceshuttle zweimal war er pilot nur
eine handvoll menschen auf der welt
können das spaceshuttle heil auf die
erde steuern
heute fliegt er als copilot eine 737 als
ehemaliger test pilot der luftwaffe muss
er schließlich geld verdienen und er
will fliegen kollegen im cockpit halten
manchmal den atem an angesichts seiner
vergangenheit
jeder hier möchte gerne wissen was der
andere vorher gemacht hat bevor er
verkehrs pilot wurde und so ist das auch
bei mir meine kollegen haben nur angst
dass ich bei der landung die triebwerke
abschalten aller spaceshuttle ja ein
gleiter war und ich gewohnt bin ohne
triebwerke zu landen
gutbürgerlich patriotisch sichtbarer
wohlstand 20 minuten braucht kevin vom
flughafen nach hause in einen vorort von
houston
wer hier lebt hat viel mehr als nur ein
auskommen
all die jahre als astronaut haben ihn
der erde am ende viel näher gebracht
die familie der zusammenhalt das ist ihm
heute wichtiger als der ruhm vergangener
zeiten
die familie war für mich immer sehr
wichtig meine frau und ich haben beide
große familien und wir versuchen unseren
kindern gute eltern zu sein ihnen für
das leben etwas mitzunehmen und das
hilft einem auch in der gemeinschaft den
anderen menschen in der gemeinschaft zu
helfen ist für uns sehr wichtig wenn mir
meine familie sagen würde du bist jetzt
sehr lange geflogen wir wollen nicht
mehr dass du fliegst dann würde ich
diese entscheidung respektieren
und wenn der reifenwechsel mit dem
junior dasselbe an bedeutung bekommt wie
das farewell des präsidenten dann ist
man wohl wieder zu hause angekommen
kennedy space center drei stunden vor
dem start in begleitung von
sicherheitskräften werden die
journalisten zum sogenannten crew haut
gebracht die astronauten erscheinen kurz
zum fototermin und werden dann zum
startplatz eskortiert minuten langes
warten gefolgt von zehn sekunden ruhe
den silbernen bus auf der rechten seite
kennt mittlerweile jedes kind in ihm
wurden von neil armstrong buzz aldrin
und michael ins zur rampe gebracht
[Musik]
[Applaus]
später im pressezentrum alle blicken
gebannt nach houston auf die monitore
mission control die regie für das
gesamte unternehmen
von hier aus heißt es dann go oder no go
for launch startfreigabe oder nicht aus
technischer sicht steht einem gelungenen
start nun nichts mehr im weg eigentlich
denn da ist ja noch das wetter dieses
zusammenspiel aus wolken wind und
luftdruck ist schwer vorherzusagen
zurzeit in florida eine wahre
truppenküche nahe dem äquator mal wieder
chaos
momentan stehen die chancen 70 zu 30
gegen einen staat wir haben es im moment
mit ein paar tief hängenden wolken zu
tun die in richtung startplatz ziehen
wir erwarten dass sie in etwa 30 minuten
genau wo der startrampe stehen
für außenstehende ist das schwer zu
begreifen da haben die amerikaner mit
dem space shuttle ein technisches
wunderwerk geschaffen ein weltweit
einzigartiges raumschiff eine regenwolke
aber und sei sie auch noch so klein
kannte milliarden teuren staat ernsthaft
gefährden
petrak ins erinnert sich an eine
bemerkenswerte begegnung mit russischen
kosmonauten
als das erste mal die russen mit an bord
waren da waren ein paar regenwolken über
der rampe also brach die nasa den start
ab die russen waren total überrascht und
meinten wir landen unsere sojus-kapsel
in sibirien im schneesturm wo zum teufel
ist das problem mit einer regenwolke ich
habe mal einen start erlebt da kam der
abbruch millisekunden vor dem lift oft
entdeckten die computer einen fehler in
den turbo pumpen und die ganze prozedur
wurde einfach gestoppt als wäre es nicht
die blicke der reporter sind nun stark
auf die monitore gerichtet von hier aus
kann man direkt in den missionskontrolle
raum nach houston sehen
gespannte stille vor der entscheidung
alle verantwortlichen müssen den daumen
zum start eben zweifelt nur einer
passiert hier gar nichts
[Musik]
das eine no go reicht aus der start wird
abgebrochen mal wieder bei einer wolke
im weg besonders in der nacht braucht
die nasa hier einen klaren himmel für
den staat mission control hatte wohl ein
ungutes gefühl
natürlich ist es enttäuschend für uns
alle hier aber den sechs astronauten ist
es sicher lieber sein
jetzt müssen wir es morgen nochmal
versuchen ich habe hier schon genauso
viele geglückte start wie abbrüchen
gelebt
es beginnt ein neuer tag am banana river
in florida interessiert der staat hier
niemand
[Musik]
die reporter sind wieder auf dem weg ins
pressezentrum unter den journalisten
gibt es heute nur ein thema das wetter
viele haben hier schon start abbrüche
erlebt und doch ist man irgendwie immer
wieder enttäuscht die frage also wird
das shuttle heute abend abheben die
wetter experten der nasa sind zu diesem
zeitpunkt noch sehr vorsichtig wenn es
um voraussagen für den nächsten start
versuch geht nasa wetterexperten winters
beschreibt das sensible verhältnis
zwischen tropenwetter und dem space
shuttle
wenn wir von wetterproblemen reden dann
meinen wir vor allem die gefahr einen
blitzschlag zu verursachen
selbst wenn es keine gewitterwolken über
dem staatsrats gibt kann das raumschiff
durch seine beschaffenheit beim aufstieg
einen blitzschlag verursachen
das wäre natürlich fatal für die gesamte
technik außerdem wollen wir verhindern
dass sich auf dem shuttle regentropfen
bilden denn die stören die wichtigen
sensoren die überall auf der außenhaut
angebracht diese hochsensible
beschaffenheit des space-shuttle
verlangt seinen ingenieuren extrem viel
ab in diesem gebäude so hoch wie der
kölner dom wo das ende der 70er jahre
entwickelt und seitdem ständig überholt
besonders beeindruckend die außenhaut
25.000 keramik kacheln jede maximal 12
cm dick und extrem hitzebeständig über
1200 grad celsius beim wiedereintritt in
die atmosphäre können ihnen nichts
anhaben lebensversicherung für
astronauten detailversessen überprüfen
die techniker jede einzelne kacheln mit
pinsel und stift werden auffällige teile
markiert und ersetzt die zeitspanne von
der landung bis zum nächsten start
verschlingt milliarden dollar und
unzählige arbeitsstunden zurück im
zentrum von houston auf dem weg zum
ronald mcdonald haus einer stiftung für
krebskranke kinder
für sie wird kevin kriegel heute kochen
zusammen mit anderen ehrenamtlichen
helfern die wig riegels firma southwest
an der einrichtung beteiligt sind
übrigens mcdonald's der namensgeber
dieser stiftung hält gerade einmal drei
prozent
einmal im monat kommen hier alle
zusammen für die kinder ist das eine
willkommene abwechslung während ihrer
therapie sind sie hier zusammen mit
ihren eltern untergebracht und für
familienmensch kriegel ist das eine
herzensangelegenheit würde ich mich nur
auf die fliegerei konzentrieren wäre
mein leben ziemlich einseitig außerdem
ist das hier eine sehr schöne
freizeitbeschäftigung ja ich bin ein
technikfreak ich bin ein flieger aber
ich treibe auch gerne sport und ich
glaube einfach dass der dienst an der
gemeinschaft sehr wichtig ist für mich
ist das hier kein geschäft es ist eine
familie und eine tolle möglichkeit
anderen menschen zu helfen
in kevins brust schlagen immer noch zwei
herzen
da ist der familienmensch und der
flieger die faszination für das shuttle
irgendwie lässt einen das nicht mehr los
sofort würde er wieder fliegen wenn man
ihn nur ließe
oh ja ich würde das shuttle morgen
wieder fliegen einer meiner
lieblingsfilme ist space cowboys mit
clint eastwood die szene in der sie die
pensionierten astronauten anrufen um zu
fliegen
ich warte jeden tag auf diesen anrufen
es ist später vormittag in florida gegen
11 uhr gibt die nasa ihre übliche
pressekonferenz
die stimmung ist gelöst man kennt sich
und alle hoffen auf einen start am abend
details zur mission die zielsetzung der
stand der vorbereitungen
eigentlich ist alles wie immer bis zu
der frage des amerikanischen kollegen
von cbs wie nimmt eigentlich die nasa
belegschaft die nachricht von den
budgetkürzungen auf der journalist
bittet um ein paar gedanken dazu und da
bricht es aus mike leinbach heraus die
leute sind schockiert sie sind total
verunsichert
das ist für uns alle ein herber schlag
ich war gestern mit ein paar nasa leuten
zusammen und da gab es große angst unter
den mitarbeitern
sie fragen sich was die zukunft wohl
bringen wird und sie sind unsicher wir
werden jetzt an plänen arbeiten wie wir
das alles so sozialverträglich wie
möglich gestalten können und wir müssen
das schnell tun
je schneller desto besser die menschen
wollen wissen wie es jetzt weitergeht
ihr leben ist das space shuttle
seit jahrzehnten arbeiten diese menschen
in florida an ihrem raumschiff ganzen
generationen hat es einen arbeitsplatz
und ein stück sicherheit gegeben
für knapp 7000 nasa-mitarbeiter endet
diese sicherheit spätestens am 31
dezember
viele werden bereits umgeschult ob sie
je wieder eine anstellung etwa als
flugzeugmechaniker finden ist ungewiss
mit dem neuen präsidenten obama kamen
neue prioritäten
sie heißen nicht mehr mond oder mars
sondern iss die internationale
raumstation
amerika will wieder mitmachen sich
wieder einbringen
kooperation statt prestige lautet die
neue losung aus washington den europäern
gefällt das know how der amerikaner wird
dringend gebraucht forschung und
entwicklung im weltall eine
gemeinschaftsaufgabe für das
einundzwanzigste jahrhundert
es gibt künftig nichts mehr was eine
raumfahrtnation alleine stemmen könnte
und das ist wenn sie so wollen ein neuer
stil seitens der amerikaner eine neue
kultur des miteinander
für mich ist dieser sinneswandel die
entscheidende nachricht aus amerika von
nun an wird alles international
entschieden die zeit der nationalen
prestige objekt ist vorbei
zuspruch aus deutschland hier hat man
von anfang an verstärkt auch die
wissenschaft gesetz über die rückkehr
der amerikaner an bord ist man
erleichtert
ich denke für eine industrienationen wie
deutschland ist es absolut wichtig dass
wir forschung betreiben dass wir
entwicklungen betreiben weil das
letztendlich unsere industrielle
entwicklungsfähigkeit die
konkurrenzfähigkeit und auch die
kooperationsfähigkeit in zukunft
bestimmen wird
die aufgaben die man an bord der
internationalen raumstation wahrnimmt
einem weiten spektrum von
grundlagenforschung bis hin zur
anwendungsorientierten forschung leistet
hierfür wesentliche beiträge mission sts
130 steht kurz vor dem start für die
astronauten wird es jetzt ernst
[Musik]
die haben
aufmunternde worte von den männern in
weiß hier oben sind sie schließlich die
letzten ansprechpartner für die
astronauten
denn gleich heißt es einsteigen und luke
schließen
vorsicht beim abflug
[Musik]
in drei kilometer entfernung das nasa
pressezentrum hier lässt sich alles auch
über monitore verfolgen
mittlerweile ist es die zweite nacht am
kennedy space center und dem ein oder
anderen fallen schon mal die augen zu
trotz kaffee und kater brötchen
alle warten nun auf das entscheidende
signal von flugdirektor via go for
launch wir sind startklar
und er ist immer noch gern dabei
astronaut michael hat flug mehrmals mit
dem shuttle hat später das mondfahrzeug
rover entscheidend mitentwickelt
diese technische errungenschaft wird nun
vielleicht nie zum einsatz kommen denn
die amerikaner wollen nicht mehr zum
mond zumindest nicht so schnell eine
entwicklung die gehört mit gemischten
gefühlen verfolgt
ich blicke mit gemischten gefühlen auf
die zeit mit dem spaceshuttle zurück es
ist eine tolle maschinen ist ein beitrag
zum bau der internationalen raumstation
iss
das space shuttle ist das komplexeste
fluggerät das menschen jemals gebaut
haben und wahrscheinlich wird es so
etwas nie wieder geben aber seine zeit
ist einfach und es müssen wir uns neuen
projekten widmen die uns über die
erdumlaufbahn hinaus bringen die uns in
unserem sonnensystem überall hinbringen
auch zum mars und darüber hinaus die
meisten berichte sind längst getippt die
mission der auftrag die astronauten
alles im kasten
smalltalk zeitvertreib ist es endlich
losgeht denn das eine bild das
entscheidende
das fehlt eben noch der start und das
macht ihn zum gefragten mann wie
entwickelt sich das wetter wolken sind
jetzt das allerletzte was man hier noch
brauchen kann
aber der wetterdaten beruhigt so weit
sieht alles ganz gut aus
von ihm aus kann es losgehen der wagen
quer listenpreis health checks
[Musik]
ich wollte ihm den rücktritt nahe
und die betriebe und ruhig
[Musik]
die nasa hat heute geschichte
geschrieben denn eine nächsten shuttle
start in der nacht wird es definitiv
nicht geben
wie oft das space shuttle noch abheben
wird steht in den sternen
was ist das für ein gefühl heute hier zu
stehen beim definitiv letzte nachtstart
eines shuttle
es ist schon ein besonderes gefühl weil
das alles hier war ja ein teil meines
lebens mein erster start war bei
challenger 1986
ich war hier bei den höhepunkten und den
absoluten tiefpunkte der nasa ich habe
von hier aus über die columbia
katastrophe berichtet es ist das ende
einer ära
es ist ein großartiges stück technik bei
all seinen fehlern
aber wenn man
nachtstart zu gesicht bekommt und
entschädigt das für alles
[Musik]